mary ha 24 anni
e scritta biologia ed è un po in ritardo
con gli esami
cosa che genitori le ricordo non giorno
sì e l'altro pure
ma a me eri abituato a tutto questo
quindi non solamente risponde poco
i genitori di mary e sono entrambi i
medici si sono conosciuti all'università
ed erano la coppia di successo per
eccellenza
mary ammira molto sui genitori ma non ha
mai neanche pensato di poter aspirare a
diventare come loro ormai vuole
laurearsi e basta non sa cosa vorrà fare
dopo
ma eri abituato a sentirsi non
abbastanza brava mai abbastanza
brillante ma è abbastanza intelligente
si sentiva così fin dalle sue origini
fin da bambina
fin da quando alle elementari doveva
leggere avanti a tutta la classe così
come anche i suoi compagni solo che a
lei non riusciva molto bene i compagni
infatti la prendevano in giro per la sua
lettura lenta e sbagliata per il fatto
che portava gli occhiali e anche per il
fatto che non era studiata come le altre
bambine
mary nel corso del tempo con il
perpetrarsi di questi eventi purtroppo
ha iniziato a chiudersi sempre di più a
pensare sempre peggio di se stessa e non
ambire alle cose che realmente voleva
perché pensava che non ce l'avrebbe mai
fatta
questo fenomeno si chiama impotenza
presa ovvero la credenza e la percezione
di non essere mai abbastanza di non
poter ambire in qualcosa perché se
convinti di non potercela fare
si chiama presa perché una cosa che si
apprende nella vita non è una cosa con
cui ci si nasce una cosa che ci
insegnano gli eventi della vita
tornando a meri pensate camerini anche
piace la biologia
però per qualche ragione è sempre stata
brava a memorizzare molecole processi e
così è stata spinta riscriversi
mary amava il nuoto l'ottava fin da
bambina sarebbe stata giorno in piscina
e avrebbe tanto voluto diventare
insegnante di nuoto
solo che
non credendo di essere brava non l'ha
mai neanche detto ad alta voce
e ora mi fermo da raccontarvi di mary e
anche perché le storie delle persone
sono così ricche così complesse che
dovrei stare qui per giorni interi
vorrei piuttosto focalizzarmi su un
punto che secondo me è importante per
tutti noi qua dentro
mary così come tutti noi ha fatto delle
scelte nella sua vita sulla base di ciò
che pensa di se stessa ciò che pensa del
mondo e ciò che pensa delle altre
persone ma come ho già detto ciò che lei
pensa di se stessa del mondo e delle
altre persone non è una cosa con cui lei
annata è una cosa che ho imparato nel
corso della sua vita attraverso gli
eventi
i nostri pensieri le nostre credenze i
nostri modi di affrontare le cose
determinano tutto
determinano quello che faremo e quello
che lasceremo perdere
determinano se lotteremo per qualcosa o
se ci arrenderemo
determinano se seguiremo i nostri sogni
o se ci accontenteremo delle richieste
degli altri
determina non si alla fine avremmo
vissuto una vita piena e felice ho una
vita a metà
questo significa per me
una cosa fondamentale
curare i nostri pensieri
la nostra mente i nostri comportamenti
forse la cosa più importante della
nostra vita
adesso vorrei fare un esperimento
insieme a tutti voi
chiedo a tutti di alzare la mano se
ritenete di prendervi abbastanza cura
della vostra mente e dei vostri pensieri
alzate la mano
ok
poche mani come immaginavo come vedete
non ho giocare anch'io
adesso ne facciamo un altro
alzi la mano chi desidera vivere una
vita felice
non vedo neanche una mano non alzata
ma allora io mi domando se vogliamo
tutti vivere una vita felice
perché non ci prendiamo cura della
nostra mente delle nostre credenze dei
nostri pensieri
come si suol dire questa è una domanda
da un milione di dollari
richiederebbe studi scientifici ricerche
manuali interi per ricevere una risposta
adeguata
quindi non vi darò una risposta adeguata
oggi ma cercherò di farvi un elenco
completo possibile
5 conti vi racconterò il machismo la
cultura
il tempo
il costo e lo stigma ora ve li racconto
il primo punto il machismo
nella nostra società c'è tantissimo
macismo cos'è il machismo il machismo e
il desiderio di voler apparire forti
ogni costo
nascondendo anche quelle che sono le
vulnerabilità ma non solo agli altri
anche a noi stessi
quali sono le conseguenze del machismo
le conseguenze sono che invece di
cercare di risolvere i nostri problemi
tendiamo a metterli come si suol dire
sotto al tappeto il problema è che i
problemi sotto il tappeto non spariscono
al massimo fanno una gobba al tappeto
secondo punto di cui voglio parlare la
cultura intesa come cultura del
benessere
oggi c'è una pessima cultura del
benessere mentale ovunque pessima si
credono cose sbagliate sulla psicologia
sugli psicologi sui di psichiatri ma
soprattutto non si sa cosa realmente
questi professionisti della mente
possono fare per noi
quante volte avete sentito dire per
esempio
non ci vado dallo psicologo tanto
ascolta e basta
tanto vale se devo solo parlare senza
ricevere risposta parlo con un amico che
è gratis
non solo lo psicologo parla eccome ma lo
psicologo anni di esperienza di studio
alle spalle che vostro amico non ha non
a caso qualcuno decide di pagarlo no
oppure quante volte avete pensato ho
sentito io non sono pazzo perché dove
andare da uno psicologo
lo psicologo fa bene a tutti pazzi
inclusi tutti
il terzo problema che voglio portare il
tempo
oggi noi corriamo corriamo corriamo
continuamente non ci fermiamo mai quindi
fermarsi a riflettere sulle proprie
origini sulle proprie difficoltà su
quello che si sta vivendo sulle proprie
emozioni anche sulle proprie sofferenze
molto spesso è un lusso che non ci
concediamo
il tempo lo intendo anche in un altro
modo per esempio il tempo che dopo 89 ma
anche 12 ore di lavoro non ci va
assolutamente
stanchi di rimettersi in macchina o in
metro per andare a fare qualcosa che
comunque è difficile
non ho tempo è una delle scuse di
quest'epoca anche per la salute mentale
il quarto punto era il costo no
tendesse quella della fragranza out e
mentale poi un corso anche alto
questa epoca non è famosa per un boom
economico è famosa per la crisi quindi
moltissime famiglie devono fare dei
conti ben oculati per decidere come
allocare il proprio denaro e molto
spesso la salute mentale non rientra in
tutto questo
la bilancia una preoccupazione in quanto
costa non farlo
l'ultimo punto lo stigma
io sono la psicologa nonostante gli anni
vissuti i libri gli amici psicologi con
cui è ancora parlo ogni giorno i
pazienti con cui lavorato la cosa che
nella vita ho più sentito spesso sono
credenze errate e sigma questo per dirvi
cosa che lo stigma è un male ancora
molto diffuso e ostacolante ostacolante
perché non permette di alcune persone di
fare quel passo
dove voglio arrivare io voglio arrivare
una cosa molto semplice che la cosa più
importante della nostra vita
la stiamo facendo male
il concetto di salute mentale è un
concetto che molto spesso fa paura sia
per i punti elencati prima sia per tanti
altri
se non ci fa paura siamo scettici
se non siamo neanche scettici siamo
scoraggiati
se non siamo scoraggiati troveremo
comunque un ottimo motivo per non
prenderci ne cura
noi psicologi vi assicuro che spesso
incontriamo persone che poi diventano i
nostri pazienti che prima di rivolgersi
a noi hanno aspettato anni anni e anni
con la stessa difficoltà con lo stesso
problema
prima di fare qualcosa problemi che
erano risolvibili poi ci tengo a
sottolineare una cosa che si fraintende
spesso quando io parlo di problemi
psicologici non mi riferisco solo a
quelli da diagnosi quindi come può
essere la depressione e attacchi di
panico l'anoressia al bipolarismo tanti
altri
quando noi parliamo di problemi
psicologici difficoltà psicologiche noi
ci riferiamo nella stragrande
maggioranza dei casi a problemi che non
hanno la diagnosi ma che sono proprio
parte della vita di ogni giorno vi
faccio alcuni esempi
difficoltà familiari coi nostri genitori
con i nostri figli che vanno avanti come
dicevo per anni a volte no che non si
riescono a superare dinamiche che si
ripetono col nostro partner che non ci
piacciono che ci fanno vivere male non
riusciamo a superare ce l'abbiamo messa
tutta e tutti i modi e non riusciamo a
superarle
oppure sentirsi spesso preoccupati non
ansia concetto che si sente spesso
sentirsi spesso preoccupati anche senza
un motivo valido
posso continuare a vostro citarvi
dormire male permira agitati e
svegliarsi stanchi le difficoltà se su
logiche che non ci fanno vivere bene la
nostra sessualità per esempio oppure non
riuscito a raggiungere le performance
che si desiderano sul lavoro
potrei continuare
questi problemi
primo dopo alcuni di questi possono
presentarsi nella nostra vita non dite
che non è vero perché sareste prendendo
in giro una psicologa ma soprattutto se
si vendono in giro voi stessi
vi faccio alcune domande invito
mentalmente a dare delle risposte
se vi siete riconosciuti in qualcuno di
questi problemi se sapete che ce ne sono
altri provate a pensare se in passato le
osterie superati risolti oggi lo stress
e vivendo meglio non pensate che anche
se non parliamo di depressione non
parliamo di anoressia non pensate che
questi problemi comunque meritano
ascolto risoluzione
esempio se i problemi familiari molto
comuni difficoltà con genitori con figli
l'avessimo superati tempo fa oggi non
staremmo meglio
se come anche mary fin dalle sue origini
non avesse lavorato sulla percezione
negativa di se stessa
raggiungendo una migliore autostima un
migliore equilibrio
non avrebbe fatto scelte diverse per la
sua vita
tutto parte dalla nostra mente
prendersi cura della propria mente
è il motto di amore che possiamo fare
nei confronti di noi stessi
se vi siete riconosciuti in qualcosa che
raccontato e non lo avete ancora fatto
non vi siete ancora presi cura della
vostra mente invito a pensare per
iniziare
io sono daniela de stefano sono la
psicologa e sono fondatrice di un
servizio di psicologia online che non
solo dal supporto psicologico
psicoterapia a più di 30 mila persone
in questo momento ma che ha come
ambizione ancora più alta quella di
combattere tutto questo lo stigma la
disinformazione e i blocchi che ogni
giorno diamo alla nostra vita senza un
motivo valido
vi voglio lasciare con un'ultima storia
che ho raccontato anche a mary a suo
tempo che ovviamente un nome di fantasia
questa storia è molto semplice semplice
come il
messaggio che vuole dare
ovvero che prenderci cura della nostra
mente del nostro corpo è la cosa più
importante nella nostra vita
una volta in un circo
c'erano elefantino
era molto vivace quindi pur essendo
piccolo faceva dei danni dei disastri
nel circo quindi desistero di legarlo a
un palo con una corda
l'elefantino protestò animatamente cercò
di sradicare quel palo in tutti i modi
di staccare la corda ma non ci riuscì
mai
tempo dopo
l'elefantino divenne elefante nel
circolo tenevano legato sempre con la
stessa corda sempre allo stesso palo
qual è la differenza la differenza è che
le fronti adulto avrebbe potuto
praticare quel palo o staccare la corda
in due secondi
solo che l'elefante non ci prova mai
perché ormai era convinto di non
potercela fare
cosa ci insegna
questa fare molto semplice di nuovo
che dalla nostra mente
parte tutto quello che facciamo quello
che decidiamo per la nostra vita se
nella vita implicitamente
abbiamo imparato delle cose dannose
ma molto impattanti abbiamo due scelte
possiamo decidere di comportarci di
conseguenza per sempre
oppure possiamo decidere di fare pulizia
nella nostra mente e imparare nuovi modi
di vedere le cose di affrontare i
problemi e anche di relazionarci alle
altre persone in questa sala in un modo
o nell'altro
siamo stati tutti elefantini io vi
invito oggi a uscire di qui e sradicare
ogni singolo paolo della vostra vita
grazie
[Applauso]